16h 17 ans ça aurait été aussi bien ah
pourquoi vous pensez qu'à ces gens au 17
ans on puisse conduire une voiture je
pense
en avoir ou pas elle est la question que
ce sont posées pendant ce mois du salon
de l'automobile ceux qui rêvait
d'acheter une voiture et ce qui
n'avaient pas encore l'âge d'en avoir
une à cela lycéens involtaire nous avons
posé quelques questions
rêvez vous d'avoir une voiture pas
spécialement
[Musique]
va te perdre je suppose non je ne me la
paierai par mon travail personnel en
quelque sorte
je travaillerai pendant les vacances je
ne sais pas par exemple à l'American
Express ou ready Jess je ne sais pas
vous offrir une voiture j'aimerais une
voiture mais pour mettons à un groupe
acheter une vieille voiture un groupe et
puis faire des balades de partir en
vacances et m'avoir une voiture voir où
tout seul ça ne vous intéresse pas
bah parce que d'abord je m'ennuierais si
on est tout seul dedans c'est normal et
puis j'aime bien justement cette espèce
de groupe on est enfermé une sorte
d'ambiance une voiture eSport ou un
objet utile ou un objet de luxe non
c'est un objet de luxe à notre âge de du
moins c'est un objet de luxe j'ai pris
la voiture respectant le métro ah oui
c'est mieux que prendre le métro et
pourquoi c'est plus pratique c'est
plus agréable pourquoi plus agréable
expliquez-moi
je Bossieu si vous avez pris le métro
vers 6h ou de vous en rendre compte tout
seul quoi c'est surtout plus confortable
mais à Paris le métro honnêtement plus
rapide je pense et c'est meilleur pour
les nerfs en tous les cas avez-vous des
camarades qui viennent au lycée en
voiture non moi j'en connais pas et j'ai
un camarade qui vient de temps avec la
voiture de son père quand son père est
en déplacement et son père voyage en
train et il prend la voiture pour venir
au lycée comme ça l'admirez-vous
particulièrement parce qu'il vient en
voiture au lycée
au lycée parce que c'est un manque
camarade n'est pas parce qu'il vient en
voiture à quel âge penser pour être
capable de conduire une voiture à mon
âge vers 18 19 ans c'est encore assez
jeune pensez-vous que là j'ai 18 ans
soit bien chassis pour la délivrance du
permis de conduire oh oui certainement
parce que même même 18 ans c'est
dangereux de confier une voiture un
jeune peut-être un peu trop jeune moi je
me rends quand même compte que je vais
bientôt avoir 18 ans mais que ça capable
oui ok
c'est pour ça que je préfère un
instrument plutôt lent c'est trop jeune
parce que à 18 ans je pense que on a
trop tendance à vouloir faire de la
vitesse quelle est la qualité
primordiale pour une voiture pratique
luxueuse ou rapide
pratique pourquoi pratique pour si on
s’insère pour son travail pour moi
rapide et confortable pratique je pense
rapide pour un jeune et puis pratique et
luxueuse pour qu'elle conclure
et maintenant rendons visite aux jeunes
ouvriers de chez Renault qui eux
fabriquent ces objets merveilleux
messieurs s'il vous plaît messieurs
est-ce que je pourrais vous poser
quelques questions sur l'automobile
est-ce que vous rêvez d'avoir une
voiture oui pourquoi
j'aime la voiture ah oui beaucoup
pourquoi
c'est beaucoup plus pratique comme moyen
de locomotion c'est plus rapide non pas
tellement pourquoi le risque comme tout
le monde une voiture est-ce que c'est
pour vous un objet utile ou un objet de
luxe
de luxe pourquoi parce que il y a
beaucoup d'ouvriers qui ne peuvent pas
se passer la payer et circuler en
voiture est-ce mieux que prendre le
métro oui pourquoi
il y a un certain confort on ne trouve
pas dans le métro ah oui 5 ans que je
prends le métro que j'en ai assez
avez-vous des camarades qui viennent à
l'usine avec une voiture est-ce qu'il
vous est ce qu'il vous est
non ils sont sympathiques comme garçon
ils ne sont pas cela parce qu'ils ont
une voiture
pour l'attribution du permis de conduire
à quel âge souhaiteriez-vous que vous
l'attribue
17 ans 17 ans et alors vous tenteriez
votre permis tout de suite
ça dépend encore des gens ça dépend des
personnes il y en a certains à 18 ans
qui conduisent prudemment alors que
d'autres même à 20 ou 21 ans sont encore
un peu chouchous au volant pensez-vous
que 18 ans soient un âge bien choisi
pour l'attribution du permis de conduire
non pourquoi on est trop jeune pour
conduire une voiture en stage là quel
âge vous avez vous à 18 ans et demi oui
mais un peu plus sérieux de l'examen
c'est-à-dire que par exemple médical vu
tout ça faudrait que ce soit le plus
sérieux et que ce soit pas un peu de la
fumée historique comme à l'heure
actuelle
c'est bien ah pourquoi
vous pensez qu'à 16 ans au 17 ans on
puisse conduire une voiture je pense oui
sans danger sans danger quel âge vous
avez révolution
quelle est la qualité primordial pour
une voiture pratique luxueuse ou rapide
luxueuse rapide je mettrais plutôt
luxueuse ça dépend certains goûts pour
certains ce sera la rapidité à quel âge
pensez-vous qu'un jeune ouvrier doit
passer d'une voiture
en revenant du service militaire
pourquoi justement en revenant de
service militaire
ben il commencera déjà à gagner sa vie
et puis il peut se marier en revenant du
service militaire parce que il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui se marient en
revenant et ça va avec la famille ça va
avec la famille
en vérité voilà une sagesse qui mérite
des lauriers nous serions nous tromper
une fois pour toutes sur les rapports de
l'automobile avec la Genèse
[Musique]